2021 has already seen the loss of a
number of hollywood stars
from screen legends of bygone eras to
the people who were still in their prime
that we said goodbye to
way too soon these are the actors we
lost in 2021.
new york-born actor jafet koto who
appeared opposite roger moore as a
corrupt caribbean politician in the
james bond film live and let die
and later played engineer dennis parker
in ridley scott's 1979 sci-fi flick
alien
died in the philippines in march 2021
his wife confirmed the news in a
facebook post writing
you played a villain on some of your
movies but for me you're a real hero
a good man a good father a good husband
and a decent human being
he was 81. koto made his movie debut
aged 23 in nothing but a man a film
about a black couple dealing with racial
discrimination
in 1960s alabama his sheer size led to
him being cast in a variety of hard man
roles
in the years that followed something
that always bothered him he once told
the baltimore sun
and want to try to play a much more
sensitive man there is an aspect of
black people's lives that is not running
or jumping
other notable credits include the
stephen king adaptation the running man
in which koto fought for his freedom
alongside arnold schwarzenegger
and the 90's police procedural series
homicide life on the street
award-winning actress jessica walter who
won an emmy for her turn as a san
francisco cop in ironside spin-off amy
prentice
and became known to later generations
for playing lucille bluth in arrested
development
and voicing mallory archer in archer
died in her sleep in march
2021 daughter brook bowman said in a
statement a working actor for over six
decades her greatest pleasure was
bringing joy to others through her
storytelling both on screen and off
while her legacy will live on through
her body of work she will also be
remembered by many for her wit
class and overall joy de verve she was
80 years old
the new york-born walter began her
career on broadway and
quickly started turning heads picking up
the clarence darwin award for most
promising newcomer for her work in the
show
photo finish she continued to impress
after making the move to the big screen
where walter played clint eastwood's
knife-wielding ex-girlfriend
in the actor's directorial debut 1971's
play misty for me
earning a golden globe nomination in the
process she was up for multiple enemies
over the course of her career
including for arrested development i
don't have the milk of mother's kindness
in me anymore
yeah that otter's been dry for a while
though hasn't it
kind of british character actor paul
ritter who went praise for his powerful
performance in hbo's golden globe
winning mini-series chernobyl
died of a brain tumor in april 2021
at the age of 54. rita was well known in
theater communities
on both sides of the atlantic having
been nominated for both an olivier award
and a tony award in his time he made his
on-screen bow in 1992 with an appearance
in a long-running police procedure
called the bill
he went on to carve out a career as a
prolific tv actor
alongside his appearance in chernobyl
his best known performance came in the
british sitcom friday night dinner
where he played oddball dad martin
goodman robert popper creator of friday
night dinner
said that he was devastated at this
terribly sad news in a tribute tweet
paul was a lovely wonderful human being
kind
funny super caring and the greatest
actor i ever worked with
grammy nominated rapper and actor dmx
whose songs regularly broke the
billboard hot 100
in the late 90s and early north died
after being hospitalized in april 2021.
he was rushed to a critical care unit
following a drug overdose
but ultimately passed away at the age of
50. born earl simmons in mount vernon
new york
dmx spent much of his childhood in the
care system
after being removed from his physically
abusive mother he began developing his
gritty stage persona darkman x during
his time and he remained true to his
name as his peers started to gravitate
towards designer labels
and smoother beats songs like what's my
name and party up up in here had made
him a star come the turn of the
millennium
and hollywood soon came calling dmx
appeared in a string of action movies
around this time
for example there was 2000's romeo must
die
a martial arts heavy shakespeare
transplant starring jet li
and aaliyah and then dmx headlined in
2001's exit wounds
and 2003's cradle to the grave alongside
steven seagal and jet li respectively
he never walked away from acting and he
was still active in the industry at the
time of his death
british actress helen mccrory best known
for her terms as narcissa malfoy in the
harry potter movies
and aunt polly in all five series of
peaky blinders
died in april 2021 she was 52.
mccrory was born in london but moved to
cameroon and then tanzania with her
diplomat dad when she was just a toddler
she returned to the uk for her studies
and after a year in italy
she enrolled at drama center london she
made her tv debut in 1993
and appeared in her first movie the kate
beckinsale led thriller uncovered the
following year
she went on to appear in films like the
count of monte cristo
helen mirrens the queen and the james
bond installment skyfall
but she never lost touch with her
theatre roots
olympia dukakis the star of the stage
and screen who won an oscar for her turn
as cher's meddling mother in hit
80s rom-com moonstruck died in may 2021.
her brother confirmed in a facebook post
she was 89
a daughter of greek immigrants dukakis
was born in massachusetts
and attended boston university where she
mastered in performing arts
she met actor producer louis zorich
after moving to new york
and they would tie the knot in 1962 the
year she made her debut
by the mid-1960s she had two obie awards
to her name
and was well on her way to becoming a
respected broadway star
though she'll likely be remembered by
most for her work on the screen
dukakis was named best supporting
actress at both the academy awards and
the golden globes for her performance as
rose castorini in moonstruck
sally field who worked with dukakis on
steel magnolias called her quote
unique and talented and one-of-a-kind in
her own tribute
beloved hollywood veteran norman lloyd
who was one of the oldest living actors
in the business
died in may 2021 at the age of 106.
the new jersey born brooklyn reyes lloyd
got his first break in 1932 when he was
a student at new york university
he would eventually end up working with
orson welles playing cena the poet in
wells famous adaptation of julius caesar
his first film alfred hitchcock's
saboteur soon followed
the hit spy thriller was the beginning
of a long-lasting professional
relationship
between hitchcock and lloyd he went on
to produce and or direct over 250
episodes
of alfred hitchcock presents and the
alfred hitchcock in the 50s and 60s
lloyd was nominated for a prime time
emmy for his work on the tv movie steam
bath in the seventies
and in the following decade he became
known for nbc medical drama
saint elsewhere appearing as daniel
auslander between 1982 and 1988.
other notable roles include peter weir's
dead poets society
martin scorsese the age of innocence and
charlie chaplin's limelight
comedian and actor paul mooney who
regularly collaborated with richard
pryor in the 1970s and 80s
and later became known for his work on
in living color and chappelle show
died of a heart attack in may 2021 he
was 79.
mooney met prior at a party in the late
1960s and the pair quickly hit it off
they ended up pending an episode of
samford and son together
and would collaborate many more times in
the years that followed
including on the variety series the
richard pryor show
the stand-up film richard pryor live on
the sunset strip
and on prior's biographical vehicle jojo
dancer
your life is calling mooney brought his
patented style of comedy to kenyan ivory
wayans in living color in the 90s
coming up with characters like homey d
clown and in the following decade he
became a writer on another hit sketch
show
chappelle's show mooney also appeared on
screen in chappelle's show
playing characters such as a very
opinionated movie critic
and a nostradamus parody notable big
screen credits include the buddy holly
story
in which he played seminal singer sam
cook spike leaves bamboozled and the
mike epps led comedy meet the blacks
mooney's final film former child actor
kevin clark who played percussionist
turned drummer freddie jones in the jack
black film school of rock
died after being hit by a motorist in
may 2021
clark was riding his bicycle in his home
city of chicago
when he was struck by a car he was
pronounced dead at illinois masonic
medical center around 45 minutes later
he was 32. clark landed his part in
richard linklater's school of rock his
one and only acting credit
after he tagged along with a friend to
the auditions his mother alison clark
told the chicago sometimes he just kind
of shined
he took it on right away but he never
really acted afterward
he did however keep the music up clark
went on to play in a number of bands in
the chicago area
and even taught some classes robbie
goldberg who played with clark in the
band
robbie gold said he was motivated and
loved to write songs
his hollywood career was short but clark
was a standout performer in school of
rock
a cult favorite that spawned a broadway
show and a tv adaptation
he was photographed alongside co-star
jack black as recently as 2018
and black said in an instagram tribute
kevin is gone
way too soon beautiful soul so many
great memories
heartbroken two-time tony award nominee
samuel e wright most famous for his
iconic portrayal of sebastian the crab
in disney's a little mermaid
died of prostate cancer in may 2021
deadline confirmed he was 74. a south
carolina native began his career on
broadway
appearing in the original production of
jesus christ superstar in 1971.
he made his tv debut in 1976
and went on to land apart in 1988's bird
the forest whitaker led biopic about
jazz musician charlie parker
he voiced king triton's fourth right
advisor sebastian
in disney's animated classic the little
mermaid the following year
a role he would reprise many times in tv
spin-offs and related disney media
he once told entertainment weekly
sebastian has given me what i've always
wanted as an actor and that's
immortality
as far as i'm concerned that's why i'm
in the business i want the whole world
to love me
remember me forever wright got the
chance to portray another iconic disney
character when the lion king came to
broadway in 1997
playing the role of simba's father
mufasa
veteran tv actor robert hogan died of
complications from pneumonia in may
2021.
he was 87. the new york-born actor
served with the u.s
army in korea and briefly trained as an
engineer upon returning
but an aptitude test told him that he
was in the wrong field
hogan secured a place at the american
academy of dramatic arts
and went on to become a stalwart on the
small screen for many
hogan was best known for his recurring
roles on classic abc shows the young
marrieds
peyton's place and petticoat affair
though younger viewers will no doubt
remember him from his turn in hbo's the
wire
hogan portrayed louis sodbarka father
and moral compass to pablo scribers nick
sabatka in 4 2002 episodes of the hit
show
renowned character actor ned beatty who
played ill-fated city boy bobby tripp
in john borman's 1972 classic
deliverance
died of natural causes in june 2021.
he was 83 a native of kentucky beatty
made his acting debut in his late teens
scoring a singing part in a local stage
production he went on to feature in the
original production of the great white
hope
which moved to broadway and ran until
1970.
two years later beatty made his
memorable and haunting movie debut and
deliverance
he would remain best known for borman's
film but baiti's most celebrated
performance actually came a few years
after it
he was nominated for best supporting
actor for his work in sydney lumay's
critically acclaimed black comedy
network
you have meddled with the primal forces
of nature
and i won't have it betty would go on to
work with many more of hollywood's
biggest directors
including richard donner steven
spielberg john cassavetes and robert
altman
ohio native lisa baines who was in 80s
films cocktail and young girls
and later appeared in gone girl and a
cure for wellness died after a
hit-and-run in june 2021
baines was taken to mount sinai
morningside hospital
but she died 10 days later she was 65.
bane's career in acting began in the
city where her life was tragically taken
she studied at new york's juilliard
school and appeared in numerous broadway
shows
she made her movie debut in tony
richardson's the hotel new hampshire
in 1984 and by the end of the decade
she was sharing the screen with tom
cruise playing wealthy butterfly bonnie
in cocktail
she worked largely in tv during the
1990s co-starring in the emmy nominated
drama series the trials of rosie o'neill
before a string of guest roles in the
likes of l.a lore star trek deep space
nine
and frasier banes would continue to
appear regularly on american tv screens
with casting directors often keen to
take advantage of her age-defying looks
philadelphia-born actress marion ramsey
best known for playing soft-spoken
officer laverne hooks in the police
academy movies died in january 2021.
her agency told the hollywood reporter
the statement read
marion carried with her a kindness and
permeating light
had instantly filled a room upon her
arrival the dimming of her light is
already felt by those who knew her well
we will miss her and always love her no
cause of death was released
she was 73. ramsay made her first
appearance as officer hooks in 1984's
police academy
after spending more than a decade in the
theater world she remained a mainstay of
the wacky comedy franchise over the
coming years
working on sixth installments rapper and
actor diron thompson better known by
stage name dzd
died of a suspected heart attack in
january 2021.
thompson who appeared as affable nurse
malik mcgrath in all 15 seasons of the
beloved medical drama er was discovered
in an unresponsive state
at his los angeles home his brother told
tmz
he was 55 thompson made his first
feature film appearance in 1991's
caller's ice
the critically panned movie debut of
vanilla ice he made his er debut in 1994
beginning a near 200 episode run on the
nbc hit
thompson had been dealing with heart
issues for over a decade
in 2009 he told radar online that he was
awaiting surgery after quote
over 10 episodes of heart failure in the
last eight months alone
doctors identified a problem with his
aorta the los angeles native was still
making music
and actively promoting his songs at the
time of his death
british actress barbara shelley who
appeared in numerous hammer horror films
during the 1950s and 60s died in january
2021.
the veteran scream queen contracted
kovit 19
after a routine hospital visit her agent
thomas bowington
told the bbc she was 88. shelley trained
in theater as a child but her good looks
naturally led her into the world of
modelling
her dream was to act however so when she
was approached with an offer while
vacationing in rome
she took a chance shelley went on to
appear in a string of italian movies
over a four year period
but it would be the work she did after
returning to the uk that she would be
best remembered for
the londoner became the go-to female
star for hammer horror
appearing in eight of the studio's
classic pictures
let me kiss you beloved soap star john
riley best known for his 11 year run on
abc's general hospital
died in january 2021. the actor's death
was confirmed by one of his daughters in
a tribute
instagram post she wrote imagine the
best person in the world
now imagine that person being your dad
i'm so grateful he was mine i'm so
grateful i got to love him
i'm so grateful i made it in time to
hold him and say goodbye
he was 86. riley made his on-screen
debut in the midwest set soap opera as
the world turns in the mid-70s
and would go on to become a regular face
on american daytime television
he scored recurring roles on shows like
the bionic woman
and how the west was won tanya roberts
was best known for playing geologist
stacy sutton opposite a much older roger
moore in 1985's her view to a kill
the 14th installment in the british
james bond franchise
the actress died from a urinary tract
infection that quote
got into her blood and developed into
sepsis a longtime partner lance o'brien
told fox news
she was 65. the new york native started
out as a model but made the transition
to acting a decade before her james bond
appearance
landing apart in the horror flick forced
entry her first major role came in 1980
when she joined the cast of the then
struggling charlie's angels
she remained busy during the 1990s when
she made her first appearance on that
70s show
playing midge pinciatti croatian
american actress mira furlon best known
for her stints on babylon 5 and last
died in january 2021 her death was
announced on her official twitter
account
the cause of death was not revealed she
was 65
born in zagreb ferlan and her husband
emigrated to america in the early 90s
amid rising tensions in their home
country settling in new york city
three years after the move she landed
what would become her most iconic role
in barrie ambassador dilen in babylon 5.
she briefly returned to croatia before
jetting off to hawaii
to play the part of danielle russo in
lost she appeared as a french loner in
20 episodes of abc's hit show
you offered to fix my music box
after all i've done to you striking you
shocking you
new york-born actor gregory sierra who
appeared in 70 sitcoms samford and son
and barney miller died of cancer in
january 2021.
his widow helen tabor told cnn he was
doing the best he could
and just couldn't do it anymore he was
quite wonderful and my heart has broken
into 400 million pieces
he was 83. according to deadline tierra
began his career as a member of the
national shakespeare company
appearing in a number of off-broadway
productions during the 1960s he made his
screen debut in a 1969 episode of the
robert wagner spy series
it takes a thief he would go on to
become a mainstay of the american tv in
the years that followed
popping up in numerous sitcoms and cop
shows
award-winning actress cloris leachman
best known for playing phyllis lindstrom
on the mary tyler moore show
and frau blewer in mel brooks young
frankenstein died of natural causes in
january 2021
she was quote one of the most fearless
actresses of our time her weapon friend
julia greene told variety adding you
never knew what cloris was going to say
or do
and that unpredictable quality was part
of her unparalleled magic
she was 94 a native of iowa leachman
moved to neighbouring illinois to study
theater at northwestern university
she dropped out before she could
graduate and took an unconventional
route to hollywood that included an
appearance at the 1946 miss america
pageant
her acting career began when she landed
in new york and got him with the actor
studio but she wouldn't come to national
attention
until she debuted on the mary tyler
moore show some 20 years later
she won two of her eight primetime emmy
awards for playing the catty phyllis
lindstrom who would later get her own
spin-off
phyllis i'm afraid i've just been too
much of a real woman
hollywood trailblazer sicily tyson who
paved a path for black actresses during
a career that spanned more than six
decades
died in january 2021 her manager
confirmed to variety
she was 96 the east harlem native worked
as a model before breaking into acting
appearing in top publications like vogue
she learned her craft at the actor's
studio
and became a regular face on the new
york theater scene but she'll no doubt
be best remembered for the work she did
and didn't do
on the screen tyson made her debut in
short drama
carib gold and moved into feature films
proper when she appeared as a jazz club
worker
in the harry belafonte picture odds
against tomorrow she largely avoided
movies in the decade that followed
making a conscious effort to turn down
roles that demeaned black women
she returned to the big screen with a
bang in 1972's
sounder earning a best actress
nomination for her turn as
depression-era sharecropper rebecca
morgan
you've got your low-life job mr sheriff
tyson was awarded an honorary oscar in
2019
by which point she was widely recognized
as one of the industry's pioneers
actor dustin diamond who played iconic
90s geek samuel screech powers and the
sitcom saved by the bell
died of cancer in february 2021 just
three weeks after it was revealed that
he'd been diagnosed with stage four
small cell carcinoma in a statement
published in variety his agent said
in that time it managed to spread
rapidly throughout his system
the only mercy he had exhibited was its
sharp and swift execution
dustin did not suffer he was 44 a
naturally funny child
diamond landed the role of screech with
next to no on-screen experience
he debuted as a lovable loser in 1988
on the disney channel's good morning
miss bliss which would be picked up and
revamped into saved by the bell by nbc
when it was canned after a single season
saved by the bell finished in 1992 but
diamond reprised the role of screech
on several occasions in the years that
followed most notably and saved by the
bell to college years
and saved by the bell the new class a
california native appeared in 130
episodes of the new class from 1994 to
2000
award-winning star of stage and screen
hal holbrook best known for his
portrayal of mark twain and his enjoying
one man show mark twain tonight
died at his california home in january
2021.
his agent told the new york times he was
95.
he studied drama at denison university
after graduating from high school
but world war ii forced him to put his
career dreams on hold
his first on stage performances took
place when he was stationed in
newfoundland with the us army
he joined the theater group and appeared
in a number of local productions he
began working on what would eventually
become
mark twain tonight in 1952 and four
years later
he shot to prominence after ed sullivan
invited him onto his variety show
remarkably holbrook would go on to
perform as twain over 2000 times
including two stints on broadway the
first run scored him
a tony award and he was nominated for an
emmy when mark twain tonight
transferred to tv star of the stage and
screen christopher plummer
known for a prolific career that
included playing captain von trapp
in the iconic best picture winner the
sound of music
and later becoming the oldest ever oscar
recipient
died in february 2021. he was 91.
the toronto native made his broadway bow
in 1954's the star cross story
and debuted on the big screen four years
later starring alongside henry thunder
and susan strasberg
in stage struck the actor disliked many
of the films he appeared in
during the 1960s including the one he
would come to be best known for
he famously called robert wiser's
musical quote the sound of mucus
in the 1970s plummer bagged a tony award
for his work on the musical
cyrano and then a prime time emmy for
the money changers
nbc's adaptation of arthur haley's
political thriller
he was named best supporting actor for
his turn as a gay man who comes out late
in life in 2010's beginners
making him the oldest academy award
winner at the age of 82.
he was nominated in the same category
for 2017's all the money in the world a
feat made all the more remarkable by the
fact that he stepped in to replace
kevin spacey in the role of j paul getty
just six weeks before the film was due
to be released
actress and singer trisha noble who
played the mother of natalie portman's
padme amidala in the star wars universe
died in january 2021. the australian
died quote
after an 18-month battle with
mesothelioma
a tumor caused by inhaled asbestos
fibers the daily mail reported
she was 76 born patsy and noble in
marriageville sydney
she got her start on the aussie variety
show bandstand
which featured regular performances from
the likes of the bee gees
and grease star olivia newton-john noble
saw success in australia
but her career wouldn't take off
internationally until she moved to
britain
where she secured a record deal with
columbia records
she later relocated again taking the
stage name trisha upon her arrival in
the states
she's perhaps best known for playing
jabal nabery in 2005's
star wars episode 3 revenge of the seth
actor christopher penick who appeared in
126 episodes
of the gothic soap opera dark shadows
and later occurred on general hospital
died in february 2021. he had been given
a melanoma diagnosis the previous year
deadline confirmed he was 76. panic
studied at the american academy of
dramatic arts in new york
and would go on to fine-tune his craft
of the actor's studio
before making his debut on broadway he
began with understudy work but he
quickly levelled up and started landing
roles in productions
like 1969's patriot for me which is
where dan curtis first laid eyes on him
the dark shadows creator kaspernick as
leviathan
the first of many characters he would
portray he's perhaps best known for the
twin roles of cyrus longworth
and john yeager the in-universe versions
of dr jekyll and mr hyde
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss
a single one
you